Healthcare has always been an innovative field,
and we see that now more than ever.
As technology advances, the healthcare industry is
undergoing a transformative revolution with AI leading the way.
Increased AI adoption in healthcare is bolstering our healthcare system by enhancing
the efficiency and effectiveness of
preventative care with deep learning and predictive analytics.
Don't you want to be at the forefront of advancement in
the healthcare industry and impact the future of medical care?
Udacity's AI for Healthcare Nanodegree program gives you the skills to do just that.
Be prepared to apply
machine learning and data science techniques to
cutting edge work done across the healthcare industry,
including research labs at hospitals, product teams,
and health tech companies,
R&D departments in medical schools and more.
Get hands-on experience slicing and visualizing
3D medical image data in a virtual machine using Udacity's hands-on workspace,
which allows you to perform tasks like measuring
brain size to determine Alzheimer's progression.
You'll learn to develop machine learning algorithms using electronic health records,
2D and 3D medical imaging,
and wearable device data in order to perform more accurate diagnosis,
predict health conditions, and more.
Join the healthcare revolution and enable enhanced medical
decision-making powered by machine learning to build the treatments of the future.
Enroll in Udacity's AI for Healthcare Nanodegree program today.